would you believe if we tell you that
the ceo
of a 50 crore company is listed on
forbes 30
under 30 in asia yes
it's true he is also the director of
surge impact foundation for sustainable
development
and guess what he's only 28 years old
and that's not it he was born in an
uneducated farmer's family
in a small village of andhra pradesh
as if all the odds weren't enough this
millionaire businessman
and philanthropist was born blind
let's see who this inspirational figure
is
meet srikant bola the ceo
of boland industries
srikanth is a visually impaired
entrepreneur who became
india's voice against discrimination
with the visually challenged people
but how did srikant achieve so much at
such a young age
against so many challenges the answer is
with positivity when srikanth was born
many suggested to his parents to get rid
of him as he was blind
but srikant's parents chose to be
gracious human beings
and decided to raise him with love and
compassion
they decided to give him education to
empower him
and make up for his disability
the six-year-old boy srikanth would walk
miles to go to school
but he would never complain at school
shrikant would often be left alone
children wouldn't let him play
and the teachers would treat him
differently
[Music]
although lonely srikanth continued to
focus on his studies
after his tenth shrikant was not allowed
admission in the stream of science
as the college management in india was
not sure how a blind boy
will study complex subjects and perform
experiments
like regular students only after his
perseverant efforts
and his teacher's support srikanth was
finally allowed to study science
at his own risk this was the very first
time in india
when a visually challenged boy was
allowed to take admission in the science
stream
this opened the closed gates for
thousands of aspiring students like him
srikant could never forget this feeling
and he never did
but his struggle was not yet over
srikanth aspired to join iit or bitz
pilani
but despite scoring 98 in his class 12th
his path was blocked again by the
people's perception towards disability
however by this time perseverance
and positivity had become shrikant's
best friends
so he decided to go to a university
better than the iits
he applied to the best of colleges in
the usa
and prepared very hard for qualifying
every test
soon he received acceptance from the ivy
leagues like
mit stanford and berkeley
srikanth chose mit and became usa's
first international blind student
yet again srikant proved that no
adversity
is bigger than your dreams
after passing out of mit with flying
colours
srikanth could have easily settled down
in the usa with a fancy job and an
upscale lifestyle he even had better
access to healthcare and support for
visual challenges
but srikant realized that his success
won't mean anything unless he used it
for the benefit of others
he came back to india where he found
many specially challenged students
like him still struggling to succeed
because they were not given an equal
opportunity
so he gave up the opportunity to lead a
comfortable life in the usa
to empower the specially challenged
this is when srikant started boland
industries
which produced eco-friendly products
using biodegradable packaging
boland industries is known for hiring
unskilled
uneducated and differently abled people
and yet growing exponentially
srikant even acquired funding for his
business from
several great investors including mr
ratan tata
the chairman emeritus of tata sons
today shri kant bola has won several
awards for his leadership
entrepreneurial skills and
transformational work
and all of this was possible because he
followed a single principle
all his life when the world looks up to
me
and says srikant you cannot do anything
i look up at the world and say i can do
anything does shri khan's optimism
inspire you did you notice how he faced
every challenge with open arms
are you moved by his ability to
empathize with fellow citizens
let us know your thoughts in the comment
section below
and don't forget to visit the npower
website
to learn more about entrepreneurship
happy learning
empower is running the third season of
india's future tycoons
a nationwide platform for 13 to 17 year
olds
to showcase their entrepreneurial skills
if you're interested please register for
free on their website